.
YEARS DEMOCRATIC VOTERS IN
ORART MINER
RE
AT WH WON
AT U TO BEAT A
RFNCUMBENT?
YO N WEEKS?AST, WHS
TO TEAR , ATTACKING Q
CHILDREN, ATTACKING WOMEN AND TU
VOTE, MY-OLD MY D MOTHERT
HARDER TO USE MAIL-IN BALLOT STU
WANTS TOACK.WE KNOW, TTE
MY STA NEED TO BRINGY FLORIDNDOS
HAR
GOVEOR
INSTEAD OFG ABBITION IS SO ABSU
ANODE IN.
ANE PROPERTY IANRE THROUGH THE R
CAMPAIGN, THAT IRE
THAT DEMOCRATSVE H IS THAT MAYB
HELPIS' .
OBVIOUSLTHO AL
BECAUSITHO
FEEL ABOUT HIM RE LIKECHE HAS H
NUMBERS PR MUCMON
ANY OTHER PU
NAMED DONALD TRUMP WONDER IF VT
AT YOU ARE NOW TRKNEXT
AS DEMOCRATS' LAST CHANCE  -EAY
DeSANTIS F HIGHER  POTAL IISRAT
CH BE A LO DO
I STATE
SO LET'S D.
LET'S STOP THIS THING.D I ME
NUMBERS.
PULWHAT IS , 50APPROV I
MYVA WAS.
TH 22%IFFERENCE
INDAY.YSEA.
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAINSU
KAITLAN, IT'S
BUT THIS HAS
R RIGHT
DID YOU SEE KA
KANSAS?
THAT'S LMI
FLORIDA IS A LOT DIFFERENT THAN.
WE ARE A LOT MORRA
REPUBLICA
THDEATA THIR
INDENS
ANTI-AIOBIISTINCTION FRO THIS
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
AND AS LONG AS WS
DS ACROSELP
BECAUSIFANTOJOE
BIDEN GET  TERWEEED
TO ST SANTIS DOWN IN
A NOW.
IT'S.
GO TCHARLIECRIST
TO, NOISTIME.
U  MOM
RIE ANR
UNR DEMOCRACY, TS
CHARLIECRIST.COM.
WE'RAD
ONE OR H. >> ONE THING I NOTICE
IS YOU SEEM TO B
TIEN MODEL O
HI
E TRIOTE, STANCE, YOU
KNOW, NOCEAIHE
LEFT OBVIOUSLY.
I T GIVEU TH
MO SLL
RIDA IL
I'M IDYAN.NSDECENC THE KINDNESS
FORMERY
KNOW, I KNOW HOW TO
I' DONE IT BEFORE.
FOR
STOOD UP FOR ARICANS,
FOR AUTOMATICORATION OF RIGHTSO
155,000 RETURNING, YOU KZENS, RR
BTY AN GOD
AND ARNEY SCHOOL
BEEV FORGINE'S CALLED DOING RI
THING.
HAS RIGHT FOR PEOPLE
NG WHAT'S RIGHT
FUTUREAN, GIVE ME
TO GET TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE THIS STEPPING STONE.
FLORIDA IS A S PLACE AWHAT'S RIR
STATE IS TO PUT THIS D 8th.
T WE NEED PEOPLE'S HELP ACROSSTY
O WORRY ABOUHICAUSE THW
ER 8thDID SE
HEYOU SAE SAW A PREVIEW LAST
I  HTHOUGH,  THE HEIGHT OURA
YOT.--O THAT POINT,
TALKS
BECAUSE OF HISS.NDHA,0
ELLOW
RESTAURANT OPEN, YOU DON'T -
HE DOESN'TI . THEE AND M
THAT A YOU WILL APDA BETTEFO
INDEPENDENTS MORAN HIS
GU HE KEPT
THE STATE OPEN, KEPT THE ECONOMY
RUNNING AT A TIM YOU SAW
OTHER DEMOCRAT ISOME STATES, YO
PLACE ANTH
LO LIKE,F  ATION RATELO?E DOT H.
HE DOEDOSOY R IS ASI.TANDCE CAN
ANE
PEN AND SAVE
GRADUATED FRTATE NSADD LSE OICE
LIKE HE DI OF
HESN'TNDE NSHINE STATE.
DOESNAV
PLACE
I DO.SAD
ATLANTA SIPENNSYLVANIAONA, I MOA
MAKE A DIFFEE.
A PLACE WHERU HELP P
EYSHINE STATE.
O BRING THE SUNS
BACK TO THE SUNSHINE STATEER
GOVERNOR, UNDEDeSANTIS, TH
THE ECONIS UNAFFORDABLE.
FORBES LISTED E MOST
EXPENSIVE STATE TOE IN IN
THE  MORE ANRE THA
BETTER AND WE ARGO G KS. TER AN
PERKS OF.  SUROUSE T
NORMALLYBE SEEING YOU INOU WANT?
LISTEN, LOOK WHAT JOE HAS
DONE FOR OUR -
FORGIVE, HASR Y.
WHAT'SAPPENING IN UKRAINE, HIMFH
I MEANWHAT OTHER PRESIDENT DEN,.
COULD HAVE DONE WHAT HE HAS ?PH.
GAS PRIC DOWN.ION ISREG DOWN
DEMOCRACY IS TRENDING UP.
G A GUO IST
-I
AMERICANS AND THEIR RIGHT TO
VOTE.
JOE BIDEN SUPPORTSLLTH
HE
IMAN.
T DOWNT
HE. HIS HELP.I WANT HIS- HE'S
ST I HAVE EVER MET.
HE OFFEREDH ENS CAMPGNR ME A CE
YEARS AGO DOWN INLOI LY EAT ONI
TO STAY FI